British pubs have survived
wars, floods, fires,
and more than one plague.
The question now
is can they weather
the coronavirus pandemic?
Everyone is wondering
whether the pub industry
is on the verge of collapse.
So what this chart shows
us is spending in UK pubs
compared to the same
day of the week in 2019.
Zero here is the baseline.
You can see that it
dropped by 100 per cent
- so completely -
during the lockdown.
And then, as it reopened,
spending actually
exceeded what happened in 2019
in the months between August
and even just before the
beginning of October.
Pubs had to be closed.
There really wasn't a choice.
Those people who tested
positive for coronavirus
were twice as likely to
have been at a restaurant
than those who tested negative.
And in the chart we can see it
in the blue bar, dark blue bar.
And that was also
true in the UK.
We've got here some data from
Public Health England that
shows that shopping
and eating out
were the activities most
likely to be reported
amongst those people who tested
positive for coronavirus.
So the same rings
true for the UK.
When the case count
started to drop,
the chancellor,
Rishi Sunak, decided
that once pubs had
reopened, he would actually
actively incentivise
people to go to pubs.
So people were given a
discount and encouraged
to eat in pubs and
restaurants, and bars and pubs
were the venues
that had the most
windfall from this activity.
But these venues are hotspots
for coronavirus transmissions,
so that's why we're here today
on the last day of pubs being
open in England before a
nationwide lockdown that
should last a month.
I don't have a crystal ball
to tell you what happens next.
But it's reasonable to expect
that amongst the millions
of people who work in the
hospitality industry and who
are more likely to
be young - under 35 -
women and in a part-time
and low-paid jobs,
a lot of them might
not come back to a job.
We know that the people
who have been furloughed
are more likely to be low paid,
as we can see from this chart.
Also, this chart
really shows us what's
happened to the
hospitality industry.
This is quite indicative.
It's weekly hours of work.
And we can see that
the pink line, which
is workers in the
hospitality sector,
have been more affected
than the average.
I think it's
important to point out
a bit of historical context.
The number of public
houses in the UK
have been declining for a while.
So we've gotten this chart here
- number of pubs since 2001.
There's actually
two main events that
affected the decline
in the number of pubs
and accelerated it.
One is the ban on
smoking indoors in pubs,
and the other one is
the financial crisis.
So you can see that we went
from well over 50,000 pubs
in the early 2000s
to about 39,000 now.
According to estimates,
the number of pubs
could decline by 25
per cent in the future.
However, we do know... from
this chart that I showed you
earlier... that British
people are actually very loyal
to pubs, and they're happy to
flock back when they reopen
and spend even more than
they did in previous years.
So if you're feeling very
gloomy about the future of pubs
perhaps it's not all bad news.